[Music]
Mother's Day is coming up what is
Mother's Day like in your household I
mean Mother's Day and any birthdays in
my house are kind of funny because my
kids are terrible at keeping surprises
especially the older one like she's like
mommy I got you that pink scarf you know
John's like no you know it'll usually be
the surprise we'll get busted but that's
so sweet
and love on you a little bit too or they
do but they like they might mean like
John even more than me which is slightly
upsetting at times when I ask them
little and like who's your best friend
she say I do have my friends that are
men that have daughters do tell me all
the time there's a difference with him
and that daddy-daughter mind is
something serious I mean I'm still kind
of top dog but he's got to keep him
working it so it's not that it was date
night at the premiere of Emily Blunt and
John Krasinski's new modern horror flick
a quiet place the 35 year old actress
stunned at the New York premiere in this
beautiful scarlet and soft pink Oscar de
la Renta gown with matching handbag and
shoes while her hubby looked equally
dapper in a gray suit and maroon tie
Blake Lively and Ryan Reynolds also
stepped out in support of their close
pals the fashionable woman between them
Ryan's adorable mom Tammy
[Music]
[Applause]